What is the warranty on the bulb? Is it easy to break?
There is no warranty on the bulb and
Everybody who's received the bulb is caught this little sheet of paper that says there is no warranty on the bulb and it is easy to break
Within means so I've had my bulb for years and I've never broken
I just got an email from a patient who
Broke the end off the bulb off the cord and said do I have to is this easy to fix or do I have to I just buy a new bulb
Well, if it's the end that plugs into the P220 machine or the thrift machine
That is
relatively easy to repair
So I told him just send it back to me. I'll repair it. There'll be a fee for that repair and
It's nominal and I'll set it back to you and you'll have a bulb that works just fine
if the cord that attaches to the
The bulb part of it itself comes out or dislodges
That is not repairable
Remember by definition a Tesla tube is a gas-filled tube so within that glass tube
That's inside the plexiglass
protective tube with the in that glass tube is a gas and
If the wire that attaches to it becomes dislodged or
Or cracks off the gas will dissipate and the tube is a loss and you have to throw it away
It's not repairable. I
Can't even send it back to the tube manufacturer to repair it. It's the cost the same as getting a new bulb
so
Remember there's no markup on the bulb so the bulbs are the cost. That's what I pay for them
That we're not making anything off the bulb so
There's no warranty. So is it easy to break?
If you bulk it just right
We need on the end of the bulb where the wires connect to the
Inside that plastic tube if you just bonked it against your headboard or you draw a fellow the ground and it hit just wrong
then yes, it's it can easily break that connection and
and
The tube is a loss
So it's I've had people that have had bulbs for 15 years and
They just never hit it wrong and I've had people that have had it for a couple months and
You know, I'm not in your home. I don't know how your home operates. I don't know
You know, it can be just some weird thing that you're just banging against the headboard or
You it fell on the ground and it fell just wrong. So
And there's no warranty. So if the bulb stops working
You know, you can set it back to us and I can check to see if it is just the connection if it's at the connection where the
Where the wires connect to the right machine
That is always repairable and I've repaired that out of several people
Over the years lots of people over the years. That's very repairable. If it's at the connection where the wires connect to the bulb itself
Then that's not repairable. So that the gas will leak out and it's a loss
If the Plexiglass cracks, let's say you dropped the bulb and it cracked the Plexiglass. You have a tile floor
Let's say you're your five-year-old grabbed it and spanked it super hard against the edge of a table and it cracked the Plexiglass
But the bulb still works the Plexiglass is is just a protective sheet. It that means nothing
So if the Plexiglass is cracked or busted, it doesn't even it doesn't even matter as long as the bulb is working
So in the crystal bulbs, you'll have some of the crystals that will fall off as you move it and stuff like that
That's normal. It's just don't worry about it
I've had people with very old crystal bulbs where patches of crystal fall off
That's okay, too. It doesn't need to have crystals on it. That's an added feature
So I remember when there was no crystal bulbs. It was simply the bulb
That's fine. The crystals just give a different delicacy of the frequencies to be able to hit just
It's just it's just an add-on. It's not necessary. I had for years
I had a bulb that was not a crystal bulb. That's what I used for my cancer was
a true life bulb that was not a crystal bulb. So
But yes, if you just hit the bulb just wrong
Especially you're going to be hitting the ends of the bulb itself would be just wrong the bulb could lose its gas and then it's
It's toasted. It's done
But the wires are usually easy to fix if it's at the end and that's fixable
So you do have to be very very careful with your bulb
This is a delicate piece of equipment so you have to be careful with it